-Here at "Late Night,"
every night,
I deliver a monologue
comprised of jokes
written by a diverse team
of writers.
As a result, a lot of jokes
come across my desk that,
due to my being
a straight white male,
would be difficult
for me to deliver,
but we don't think that should
stop you from enjoying them.
So we'd like
to share them with you now
in a segment called
"Jokes Seth Can't Tell."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, everybody,
these are two of our writers,
Amber and Jenny.
-I'm black.
-And I'm gay.
-And we're both women.
-And I'm not.
So, here's how this works.
I will read the setups
for these jokes,
and then Amber and Jenny
will read the punch lines.
Here we go.
A Virginia woman was arrested
for public intoxication
last week after she was spotted
carrying a suitcase
with three cats inside.
-Said lesbians, "Three?
Where are the rest of her cats?"
[ Laughter ]
-"Esquire" magazine recently
featured a profile
on the hardships of growing up
white, middle class, and male.
-Said black people,
"Ooh! Fiction."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-According to new data,
American women
are now more educated than ever.
-And if they get
just a little smarter,
they'll stop dating men.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-President Trump
said this weekend
that he thinks African-Americans
like him a lot.
-No word yet
on who told him that.
It was Kanye.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-And, Amber, real quick,
are you a Kanye fan?
-I was until he died.
-Oh, he's not dead.
-He's dead to me.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-A new lesbian romance
starring Kate Winslet
and Saiorse Ronan
is facing backlash
from people who say
the women it's based on
weren't really gay.
-Said lesbians,
"Shh! Just let them make it."
[ Laughter ]
-Jenny, do you like
watching things
with lesbian protagonists?
-Yes!
That's why I love this show.
[ Laughter ]
-According to a new report,
white people
are primarily responsible
for carbon emissions.
-But a black guy's
already in jail for it.
[ Laughter, audience groans ]
-"Oh, man!
I drive a Prius!"
[ Laughter ]
March is Women's History Month.
-So celebrate by giving women
what they want most --
-Quiet tampon wrappers.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-I don't --
I don't understand.
-Every time a woman
tries to quietly
take tampon out of her purse,
it sounds like this.
CKCKCKCKCKCKCK!
-Ckkckkckk!
-Ckk!
-Ckkk!
[ Laughter ]
-I thought you guys
were eating popcorn.
[ Laughter ]
Wait!
Wait. This next joke is about
an Asian woman.
You guys can't tell this joke.
-No.
But our new writer Karen can.
-Hi, everybody!
-Oh, great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do you think
she can handle it?
-Oh, can she handle
reading out loud?
Like your job's so hard.
-Right.
Fine. All right.
Naomi Osaka recently became
the first Asian tennis player
to be ranked
number one in the world.
-Said her mother,
"That'll look great
on your application
for medical school."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-All right.
Yeah!
That was great, Karen.
-Gee, thanks, Seth.
It was really hard
reading those words.
I don't know
how you do it, Seth.
[ Laughter ]
-She learned to be mean to me
from you two!
-[ Laughing ]
A company in Australia
is allowing employees
to take 12 weeks
of life leave per year,
which can be used
for travel or relaxing.
-While a company in America
will give women a half day
if they give birth
at their desk.
[ Laughter ]
-A court in Michigan
ruled yesterday
that giving the middle finger
to a police officer
is an act of free speech.
-Said black people, "You first."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey, Seth,
why don't you tell one?
-Oh, no, I couldn't!
-Come on! Just one.
-I feel like
I'll get in trouble if do I one.
-Oh, come on. Do it!
-Okay, I will,
'cause I trust you both.
-Great.
[ Laughter ]
The head of NASA claimed
in an interview last week
that the first person on Mars
is likely to be a woman.
And then, if it's safe,
they'll send the men.
-How dare you!
-You told me it would be okay!
-You should be
ashamed of yourself!
-You wrote that for me today
and handed it to me at my desk!
Lesbians and black women
are liars!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll be right back
with Issa Rae, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪